[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un numéro spécial
europe hebdo on parle bien sûr de la
catalogne le vertige de l'indépendance
l'homme de cette semaine c'est karl est
où damon le chef de l'exécutif catalan
lui et ses amis indépendantistes ont
inventé un nouveau concept
l'indépendance négociable il proclame la
république catalan indépendante mais
quelques minutes après il suspend le
processus d'indépendance pour laisser
place à la négociation pourquoi la
catalane demande-t-elle l'indépendance
et pourquoi madrid l'espagne ne veut pas
en entendre parler pourquoi madrid
refuse tout dialogue tant que la
catalogne n'aura pas à réintégrer la
constitution la catalogne sera
indépendante mais pas tout de suite
c'est l'avis de son patron le patron de
la région
c'est le titre de cette émission on en
débat sur ce plateau avec henrique
chalmé chambon bonjour européens
espagnols du groupe de l'alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux pour l'europe
vous êtes d'origine catalane ou oui mon
grand-père était de tarragone
oui voilà face à vous jean arthuis
bonjour vous êtes un look de l'économie
député européen centriste à vous avez
fait la compagne d'emmanuelle macron
lors de la présidentielle merci d'être
venus et jean quatremer que je ne
présente plus un habitué de l'émission à
vous êtes bien sûr le correspondant à
bruxelles du journal libération je
signale votre site votre blog coulisses
de bruxelles
d'abord la locution très attendu du
président de la généralitat tca relève
du domaine
c'est le patron de la région catalogne
il le dit la catalogne sera une
république mais en même temps il suspend
la proclamation d'indépendance et
appelle à une médiation on écoute et on
réagit juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés à un moment
historique et en tant que président
régional de la catalogne
j'assume le mandat d'annoncer des
résultats du référendum devant vous tous
et devant nos citoyens le peuple a
décidé que la catalogne veut devenir un
état indépendant sous la forme d'une
raie plus mal mandat rapporte une
parvenons à un accord que par la
responsabilité et le respect et dans cet
esprit le gouvernement propose que le
parlement suspendre les effets de la
déclaration d'indépendance
à condition que nous entamions dans les
semaines qui suivent le dialogue sans
lequel il est possible de parvenir à une
solution bi yarakh 549 possible arrivée
en cours
[Musique]
voilà république catalogne proclamer
mais suspension du processus
d'indépendance pour laisser la place à
la négociation c'est mi figue mi raisin
vous dites quoi une riquet calvet
chambon je dis que c'est de la foutaise
très directement en fait oui oui non
c'était c'est un brigand qui a
délinquants qui se permet de d'agir
contre la démocratie les citoyens
espagnols avec des mensonges et avec des
manoeuvres absolument inusable en europe
de nos jours c'est à dire et là aucun
droit de déclarer aucune indépendance
il n'a aucun droit de faire appel un
peuple qui n'existe pas et qui en plus
de ça dimanche dernier lui a dit très
clairement que les catalans ils veulent
pas sortir de l'espagne mais en plus de
ça c'est un monsieur qui a fait ce
discours pour la presse internationale
elle pour essayer de trouver des appuis
dans l'international on ne dialogue pas
avec des délinquants nez avec des
putschistes cette nature de ce qu'il
doit faire
probablement c'est l'espagne n'a jamais
parlé avec le thé à pour régler le
problème du terrorisme basque parce que
ce que vous êtes en train de dire ce
héros clair qu' on ne parle pas avec des
gens qui empruntent la voie quand même
du dialogue et vous avez discuté vous
avez parlé vous avez négocié pour mettre
fin au terrorisme au pays basque
donc c'est étonnant quand je vous
entends j'ai l'impression qu'on a
affaire à une bande armée qui est en
catalogne et qui menace l'intégrité
physique de l'espagne ce qui n'est pas
le cas c'est votre votre langage est un
langage de guerre civile alors que vous
avez des gens vous pouvez considérer qu
effectivement ils sont hors légalité
mais ils n'ont pas dit qu'ils allaient
prendre les armes contre l'état espagnol
donc je trouve votre votre langage est
un est un langage qui est justement
lui-même totalement inusité au sein de
l'union européenne
depuis des années chaque fois que
j'entends ça guerre civile absolument
impossible parce qu'il n'y a pas d'armé
à laquelle s'affronter
là le respect des lois sur les jeux
condamneront qui ce soit à condamner les
dialogues avec le thé à n'ont pas
empêché que l'on finisse par la loi avec
le des âmes et par conséquent que les
gens soient en prison et les dialogues
avec le thé à il faut approfondir
là-dessus qui les a fait pas le
gouvernement d'espagne
c'est un autre débat jean arthuis la
catalogne natale de bonnes raisons de
demander son indépendance de proclamer
son indépendance et de la suspendre
moi je ne suis pas le mieux placé pour
en juger jean quatremer est à un
européen favorable aux aux identités
régionales non non non fait pas dire ça
non mais cela dit la bretagne libre
cela dit je crois qu'il faut être très
très prudent cette matière il ya
probablement une certaine diversité
malgré tout en espagne et de forte
identité régionale est sans doute le
souhait exprimé par grandes régions de
s'affirmer et d'avoir plus d'autonomie
là on était un peu fort avec la
dépendance mais ce qui me frappe c'est
la disjonction entre la réalité et la
réalité économique et monétaire et puis
les velléités politiques
on voit bien que à l'heure de la
mondialisation et de l'union européenne
il suffit plus de s'affirmer de se
proclamer république que catalan les
banques catalan qu'est ce que voulait
dire il ya des conséquences économiques
souligne jon qui le rôle
laurent de madrid le rôle de la monnaie
unique on vient de prendre la mesure de
ce qu'elle représente les industriels
les entrepreneurs les banquiers les
financiers ne peuvent en aucune façon
accepté l'instabilité
si la catalogne devient une république
la première prérogative c'est de battre
monnaie quelle sera cette monnaie ça ne
peut pas être leur ossature helmand
et donc là le monde économique dit stop
ça ne marche plus c'est ça la novation
qu'on a un problème avec madrid madrid
est gouvernée par mariano rajoy parti
populaire le parti populaire a des
éléments en son sein qui viennent du
vieux franquisme c'est la réalité il ya
une partie qui est proche des anciennes
phalange il faut le dire comme ça et
qu'ils sont donc d'une raideur
absolument incroyable il faut voir le
problème catalans n'y a pas de
l'indépendantisme catalan dans
l'histoire effectivement le peuple
catalan ça permet il faut pour en parler
dire il n'ya pas de peuple catalan ya un
peuple basque sans doute le peuple
catalan moi j'ai un doute ya une langue
catalane mais qui ce problème il a été
créé de toutes pièces par les majorités
successives et notamment par mariano
rajoy parce qu'en 2006 et un statut
d'autonomie qui régler complètement la
question le delà de la catalogne qui
avait été approuvée à la quasi-unanimité
des cortès à l'unanimité du parlement
catalan et par un référendum en
catalogne et mariano rajoy a fait un
recours devant le conseil le conseil
constitutionnel pour voir les
conséquences youn est lassé des juges
nommés par les partis politiques là bas
c'est un peu c'est un peu particulier
comme vonn qui a annulé en 2010 ce
statut et c'est à ce moment là qu'est
née la revendication d'indépendance
ah oui ça prendra mais ententistes
aujourd'hui au pouvoir en kata 2010 en
fait voilà en 2010 il faut savoir quand
les neuf artistes voir qui c'est un peu
dire que vous avez d'un côté ils sont
minoritaires d'abord on voit 48% n'y a
pas de majorité dans les sondages qui
donnent un pour vous qui lui permettrait
proclamé l'indépendance c'est une
réalité aussi
c'est un gouvernement qui est tenu par
un groupe d'extrême gauche europhobe
quasiment stalinien la coupe est donc
ils sont entre les mains de ces de ces
extrémistes
donc ces sont des gens qui effectivement
joue la politique du pire et il agite un
chiffon rouge devant un parti qui ne
veut pas négocier
je suis désolé c'est à dire que donner
des coups de menton du style il viole la
loi la constitution est un touche à une
constitution c'est pas intouchable
constitution peut la modifier celle de
78 il ya un mois un autre il faut
s'asseoir à table pourquoi il faut
s'asseoir à table
parce que plus le gouvernement central
se raidit en disant n'y a pas de
problème catalan plus vous en créez un
de toutes pièces c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui moi je n'étais pas favorable
à l'indépendance catalane n'est
absolument pas mais vu ce que j'ai vu le
1er octobre la violence de la guardia
civile envoyés sur place pour empêcher
les gens de voter de voter un pas de
prendre les armes
ça a été quelque chose qui m'a
effectivement plus tôt
tourné en faveur des catalans justement
avant de poursuivre je voudrais qu'on
revienne en images sur ces deux semaines
de tensions entre d'un côté le
gouvernement de madrid et de l'autre les
partisans de l'indépendance de la
catalogne de la catalogne à tout a
commencé ne par ce référendum
hors la loi le 1er octobre où regarder
on réagit juste après
[Musique]
c'est le dernier acte d'une crise
institutionnelle sans précédent et ce
par la scène se joue en catalogne
la région la plus riche du pays depuis
plusieurs semaines deux camps
s'affrontent d'un côté le gouvernement
de madrid
de l'autre la généralitat tu le
gouvernement régional de la catalogne
[Musique]
premier acte dimanche 1er octobre plus
de deux millions de catalans tenté de
voter sur la question de l'indépendance
alors même que madrid il était
totalement opposée affrontements police
contre indépendantiste plus de 100
personnes blessées
le soir même les dirigeants catalans
déclare que 90% des votants ont choisi
l'indépendance avec une participation de
42%
[Applaudissements]
aurillac
deuxième acte mardi 3 octobre sept cent
mille personnes défilent à barcelone
contre les violences policières
la réaction de madrid nous devons nous
battre et nous sommes des démocrates des
gens qui veulent faire les choses bien
mais ils ne nous laissent pas faire les
choses bien
alors carrément chez je n'ai même pas
fait la liberté ce que nous voulons
c'est la démocratie et la liberté
nous nous battons en silence pour elle
depuis tant d'années et supportons la
répression du gouvernement et le roi
felipe 6 entre en jeu quelques heures
plus tard il se montre intraitable face
aux séparatistes
ces autorités catalanes se sont de façon
claire et sans équivoque mis en marge du
droit et de la démocratie
le lendemain plusieurs indépendantistes
sont convoqués par la police accusé
d'être séditieux en face certains
invoquent la dictature de franco
une époque où la langue et la culture
catalane était opprimé
[Applaudissements]
troisième acte dimanche 8 octobre ce
grand rassemblement à barcelone ils sont
plus de 350 milles à battre le pavé
ils sont venus de dire non à
l'indépendance de la catalogne
un seul mot d'ordre ça suffit retrouvons
la sagesse les gens ils disent non au
sein gagne à contaminer l'espagne en
vous vous trompez pas parce que la
capitale catalane et c'est l'espagne qui
accusait l'agent les oreilles se sent
trop manipulés par le gouvernement
catalan parce que la majorité catalan
elle n'est pas un indépendantiste de son
côté le premier ministre espagnole le
conservateur mariano rajoy est droit
dans ses bottes il averti l'autonomie de
la catalogne peut être retiré par le
gouvernement de madrid pour lui
l'indépendance de la région est
contraire aux fondements de l'europe on
ne se trouve non pas l'europe
d'aujourd'hui était attaqué par le
populisme nous avons vu le pen nous
avons vu farrage nous avons vu les
résultats dans des partis d'extrême
droite en allemagne sont donc une autre
forme de populisme ce populisme
nationale que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui en espagne est en
contradiction avec les principes
fondateurs de l'union européenne
pourtant nos stations problème à temps
bien développé
c'est pour cela que les gouvernements
européens ont pris position et ont
soutenu la constitution espagnole et le
principe de légalité et el principito
délègue à lula et voici la catalogne
dans le vert plus de l'indépendance
face à la crise l'union européenne
refuse le rôle de médiateur entre madrid
et barcelone bruxelles ne veut surtout
pas empiéter sur la souveraineté de
l'espagne ni attiser les revendications
régionalistes
enrique calvet jambon le gouvernement
espagnol at il de bonnes raisons de
réagir comme cela donc intransigeance
pas de négociations avec les landes les
indépendantistes madrague de la police
ça sur six de la foutaise il y avait
sûrement quelques bavures mais je vous
assure que la police a été très
vigilante fonctionner sur des ordres
judiciaire s'est trouvé une certaine
stabilisation de la justice s'était très
mal fait très mal prévu et je regrette
les bavures qui se sont fait je voudrais
reprendre certaines je te dire qu'avant
j'étais interrompre certaines idées pour
aller nous ne parlons plus de
l'allocution bidon et hier du duché l'on
peut aisément de ballons de l'essentiel
de la question alors délinquants mais
sait on les fusils et les délinquants
sinon la peine de mort n'existe pas je
ne sais pas si vous c'est vous c'est ça
le dernier qui a jamais l'indépendance
de la catalogne c'est en 1934
oui il a été fusillés en 1940 par franco
je crois oui il a pas été fusillé par
ceux qui l'ont arrêté qu'il était la
république espagnole à ce moment c'est
eux qui l'ont arrêté
la république n'a pas perdu la ville
livrée par les français d'ailleurs y
livrer faire les français non si on va à
l'essentiel
c'est très difficile et il faisait un
temps d'aller vers vers l'essentiel en
si peu de temps parce que l'intox a eu
beaucoup de chance de s'exprimer
et là je vois que monsieur quatremer
n'en n'est pas immunisé mais didier
primault ce qu'a dit à monsieur arthuis
et très certain c'est l'effet argent la
fuite des entreprises qui a fait hier
plus de vent de face cette balle hiver
de dire oui mais là suspens c'est ça
c'est l'argent qui l'a fait revenir en
corse et commence à devenir roi la pente
deuxièmement ce qui est en jeu
réellement et je l'écrivais pas plus
tard qui est ce sont les valeurs
européennes c'est pour ça que l'union
européenne a fait très bien le mener au
parlement et le grand message a été bien
sûr évitant les bavures bien sûr alain
un dialogue et moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais il faut savoir avec qui et
sur quoi on ne veut dialogue pas avec
des délinquants et surtout respectons
choses et les chaussées l'état de droit
les choses c
l'autonomie des régions mais pas
l'indépendance surtout ne créons pas des
peuples sur des bases racistes de
suprémacistes qui n'existe pas je tiens
à tranquilliser ici les français quand
on parle de la catalogne
heureusement on ne parle pas de la
catalogne française qui pourtant
appartiendrait au peuple catalan qui est
qu'ils sont bien libre bien démocratique
il se porte très bien et nous sommes
face un mouvement proto nazis proto
nazis automne asie un mouvement pro
thomas sieben sur le racisme qui essaye
de faire basculer l'europe poutine a
très bien compris d'ailleurs miled
on dit aussi que ce sont ces
indépendantistes sont des identitaires
qui défendent donc la langue catalane et
et on dit que ce sont des égoïstes
certains disent alors leurs
contradicteurs des égoïstes qui
posterait contre les impôts donc des
coûts économiques la catalogne étant une
région riche on aura en aurait marre de
payer pour le sud comme c'est arrivé
pour pour l'italie il peut être tentant
pour une région riche comme l'est la
catalogne de prendre son indépendance en
disant bah moi on paiera pas pour les
autres mais soyons bien conscient qu'à
ce petit jeu là on risque de
déstabiliser totalement l'ensemble de
l'union européenne et les valeurs qui
sont au meilleur jeu destin commun
risque d'être mise à rude épreuve une
donc moi ce qui me frappe dans cette
affaire c'est que aussi mais les
commentateurs aussi comment at-on pu
laisser avancer un tel projet ou et sans
s'interroger sur ses conséquences
pratiques sur la faisabilité quelle
solidarité les yeux par exemple j'étais
rapide économique que quand on parle
d'argent immédiatement voit les forces
du grand capital dans les économies en
développement économique et l'emploi
non mais j'ai une réponse très vite il y
a à peu près depuis un siècle un siècle
est un peu plus et 20% des catalans qui
sont des catalans espagnols qui sont
indépendantiste deux sentiments ça c'est
vrai et ce 20% a pris les rênes avec
l'appui des anti système de la coupe que
vous avez très près de 80 stalinien des
catalans ont pris un otage à travers les
écoles et à travers les moyens
communication a pris avantage le reste
et a fait mousser la vapeur et c'est ça
qui explique qu' ils s'en foutent
finalement de l'argent chaque pc
le sentiment c'est le peuvent c'est
l'illusionniste est un régal et l'union
européenne et l'union européenne dans
tout cela par la médiation entre madrid
et barcelone j'étais sur la souveraineté
européenne et je crois que c'est
l'eurodéputé jean lamassoure qui disait
à la presse notamment vous imaginez
sarkozy accepté une médiation de juncker
président de la section dans une crise
avec la corse
bon je veux dire que il faut on peut pas
avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre à
la fois dire que on s'intègre au partage
l'ensemble aujourd'hui au passage notre
mené au passage la politique économique
on partage d'optique budgétaire on
partage la lutte contre le terrorisme on
partage la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
mais d'un seul coup il ya une crise qui
met en péril l'unité territoriale d'un
état membre important qui met en péril
effectivement les valeurs européennes et
à ce moment là est une affaire
intérieure qu'il se débrouille mais qui
sait les brouilles jusqu'à quand
jusqu'au premier sang j'aimerais juste
qu'on me dise à quel moment on va d'un
seul coup dire il ya un problème parce
que le problème effectivement et là je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec jean
arthuis le problème c'est que les
indépendantistes
moi j'ai parlé avec eux en septembre
2016 j'avais été les rencontrer à
l'encontre du monde ce qui m'a sidéré
c'est que ces gens vivent dans le déni
le plus total
parce qu'ils s'imaginent qu'on proclame
l'indépendance et vous restez dans
l'union européenne
et ils vont rester dans l'euro et hier
aucune conséquence mais jusqu'à
l'élection d'un noir le reste là mais là
où le l'union européenne aurait pu jouer
un rôle dans cette affaire pas la
médiation s'est compliquée la médiation
mais si tu devais d'y aller sur place
juncker va sur place et à monsieur car
les stocks de mon livre vous dites
n'importe quoi parce que ce qui va se
passer d'abord un il faut que l'espagne
reconnaissent votre indépendance donc
l'espagne ne reconnaît pas que ça ça n'a
pas de valeur
ensuite si l'espagne reconnaît votre
indépendance de facto vous sortie de
l'union européenne et vous sortez de
l'euro donc vous allez rompre d'abord
vos liens parce que le pays qui va
succéder à l'espagne ce sera madrid ça
sera pas la catalogne
et puis donc vous allez vous retrouver à
l'extérieur de tous les traités
existants de l'onu de l'om c'est ses
défauts vous allez coulé en l'espace de
dix ans pour adhérer à l'union
européenne faut l'unanimité des états
membres et l'espagne fera mais sinon si
les semelles rené si l'espagne reconnaît
l'indépendance
elle acceptera et ça mettra du temps je
dire que le ca sera sanglant pour
l'économie canal donc
c'est là où je reproche simplement à
l'europe vraiment et aux institutions
communautaires plus particulièrement de
ne pas inviter faire de la pédagogie
pour calmer tout le monde oui au moins
en catalogne l'euro et de l'europe
je suis d'un lieu d'accueil ce que m'a
dit monsieur 80 le problème moi je suis
assez d'accord également avec ce qui
vient dire jean quatremer mais on a un
tel respect de la souveraineté nationale
et quand quand on parle pas là de
l'immigration c'est le même phénomène on
dit voilà il n'ya plus de frontière à
l'intérieur de l'europe
il ya des frontières extérieures qui
s'occupera des frontières extérieures et
bien ceux qui ont des frontières
extérieures au nom du respect de la
souveraineté nationale est là l'une des
faiblesses de l'union européenne c'est
que si on parle de l'égoïsme catalan par
rapport au reste de l'espagne
est ce que l'europe n'est pas de temps
en temps une addition d'égoïsmes
nationaux
donc il va falloir que l'opinion
publique européenne s'empare de ces
questions et au fond les catalans vont
peut-être tour en a grand service
c'est qu'ils opèrent une pédagogie
extraordinaire pour qu'on reconnaisse
châtelet la monnaie qu'on reconnaisse
que sont les liens de solidarité et que
ça ne se reproduise pas et que les
indépendantistes qui pourrait se trouver
dans d'autres pays de l'union européenne
comprenne qu avant d'avancer à tel
projet il faut en mesurer la faisabilité
et s'interroger sur la capitale il a
raison c'est le brésil c'est exactement
la pédagogie du brésis donc un pays ne
quitte pas l'union européenne sinon ça à
des coûts une région ne peut pas se
proclamer indépendante sans cesse des
coûts importants souveraineté nationale
vous disiez indivisibilité du foyer
après la catalogne la corse ce
référendum le berry au real au berry
indépendant à partir de là les ornements
à partir de quel moment un peuple at il
le droit de s'autodéterminer
est-ce que ce qui se passe en catalogne
peut se passer en bretagne ou en corse
on a posé la question à prof de droit
constitutionnel on l'écouté on réagit
juste après
en 1958 en lien avec le droit
international
le constituant français a reconnu à
certains égards la possibilité de
cession de territoires et la liberté des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes mais ça
se comprenait bien dans le contexte
français de la décolonisation
dans ces conditions le support juridique
existait pour que certains peuples
progressivement certaines populations
liés à la france se détache du carcan
français en tout cas de l'emprise
française en revanche ne nous méprenons
pas le conseil constitutionnel nous a
bien précisé dans une décision statut de
l'accord du 9 mai 1991 que le peuple
français est unitaire la république
française est indivisible et dans ces
conditions on ne peut reconnaître une
composante corse mais aussi bretonne ou
basque par exemple du peuple français
c'est bien qu'une région qui seraient
tentés en raison de sa libre
administration d'organiser un tel
référendum viendrait heurter de plein
fouet les dispositions de la
constitution
ça pourrait arriver en france sont pas
possibles sur leurs ancrages ce
professeur de droit je peux ajouter avec
ce 4ème opus de 80 que je demanderai
trois choses à l'union européenne
mais perdre toute son ambiguïté toute
son ambiguïté
et là il a tout à fait raison parce que
oui non etc deuxièmement les c'est très
clair que les putschistes les
délinquants ne sont pas des
interlocuteurs ils étaient tous très à
l'aise pour damon a été élu chef il a
été non précisément lui non m'enfin sont
nécessaires lui oui lui il est arrivé à
nommer un gouvernement élu maire de
gérone pas l arabe sans wii et 3 et
troisièmement le très important il faut
s'occuper de tous ces catalans je
suppose que monsieur 80 les gones est
aussi peut-être la moitié et cetera qui
sont vraiment au prix mais de façon et
cela j'utilise le mot poteau nazis de
façon absolument clientéliste affolante
les enfants sont montrés du doigt parce
qu'ils demandent à part un espagnol on
va en effet descendre dans la cour à
chanter le séga gorge
comment comment je voulais qu'il ya un
racisme anti espagnole cas si on voulait
un ethnicisme supprimés absolument c'est
à dire mon dieu on doctrine et dans la
haine de l'espagne est inutile mais par
exemple auront on punit on donne des
amendes aux commerçants qui ne qui ne
mettent pas leur leurs affiches etc en
catalan et qui la met en espagnol alors
que c'est la langue de toute la patrie
d'après l'article 2 de la constitution
donc par conséquent il ya eu un
activisme énorme menée par la coupe mais
aussi par les moyens de communication et
tout ça un activisme énorme qui a
opprimé une partie de la population
catalan
là il y a des droits fondamentaux qui
sont atteints aussi et je demanderais
aussi à la aux institutions européennes
ne sont occupés moi j'ai fait quelques
demandant la commission en particulier
sur l'éducation dernière question cette
accusation contre l'europe qui
favoriserait le régionalisme les
séparatismes avec la création de puits
traité de maastricht d'un comité des
régions des fonds structurels qui
arrivent vers les régions
lorsque vous pensez véritable
sérieusement que la chine par exemple
fait partie de l'union européenne avec
le tibet que l'irak fait partie de
l'union européenne avec le kurdistan que
l'afrique faisait partie de l'union
européenne avec les multiples
revendications régionales c'est à dire
que ce genre d'accusations la jeu il ya
un moment ou un autre il faut peut-être
reculer et puis se dire maintenant le
monde entier il ya des régionalismes il
ya des affirmations identitaires
la question c'est comment elle s'exprime
est ce qu'elles sont légitimes ou pas il
ya des vraies questions pour le cas de
la catalogne
moi j'ai vraiment un sérieux doute c'est
dire que c'est l'europe qui est
responsable de ça oui l'europe peut
faire croire aux plus excités qu'ils
vont pouvoir obtenir à charles les
langues régionales au sein de l'europe
s'est laissé le conseil de l'ordre
mais on a droit devront peut être
catalan espagnol et européen
ces sacs doivent comprendre les
régionalistes et les nationalistes on
peut avoir de multiples identités
le front national en france par exemple
ne comprennent pas qu'on puisse être
français et européens les catalans
indépendantiste ne comprennent pas qu'on
puisse catalan espagnol et européen
ils se veulent juste catalan et
européens mais c'est pas l'europe qui a
produit sa l'europe au contraire
respecte les diversités j'ai respecté la
démocratie le modaf à l'europe percer là
deux vices et unie dans la diversité est
bien respectons cela a envoyé l'avenir
ça peut mal tourner cette affaire
j'espère que non j'espère que ce qui
arrivera c'est ce qu'on a dit ici comme
le bras exceed servira de leçon et que
la catalogne espagnole reviendra à la
constitutionnalité et alors ce qu'on
peut négocier c'est une réforme de la
constitution
et on peut négocier le nid le doute à
mon avis on est allé trop loin dans
l'autonomie mais ça c'est négociable est
discutable il faudrait il faudrait voir
même est bien entendu que
je pense que ça devrait au contraire
être un bon effet pour enlever d'une
fois pour toutes tous les fantasmes
nationale aux racistes de l'europe ce
sera le mode l'apa c'est la fin de repas
bio merci à vous trois d'être venus
débattre avec nous merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi la semaine prochaine vous
retrouvez nos ramadi d'ici là bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires et la rtbf radio ça comme
on dit en espagnol ou fines sahara ça
veut dire à bientôt installe à proxim en
écho catalan catalan s'il vous plaît en
14 finales à pizza à te dire à tout à
l'heure
comme ça tout le monde à ouvrir des
comptes en bonne sud et programmes à
vous à bientôt baballe
[Musique]